we finally got sight of what the type
the Prime Minister wants to do on Breck
sale what do you make of her plan well
we're very concerned about particular
aspects to it I mean we should just say
that the document published when you
leave the EU there are about 10,000
decisions you have to make we set out
our red lines at the beginning of this
process they still apply I guess the big
debate in the country is about customs
union in single market and we're
particularly concerned about the customs
union proposals because we think that
her proposals require a technological
solution that doesn't yet exist
and as I sort of off-the-shelf you know
reliable plan for a different form of
customs union that we're suggesting so
it's not good enough for us yet and and
one Centon particular on the customs
union we probably agree with those
ministers that resigned from her cabinet
last week that that particular part of
the plan is unworkable so let's just get
really clear here in its current form
will labor back the checker still well
we've not decided our sort of voting
position on the legislation that would
enable it but in its current form it's
not good enough we want a jobs first
breaks it and we don't think that Teresa
making guarantee the jobs of British
workers with the plan as it stands now
there's so the minute it looks as though
Labour's gonna form some kind of unholy
alliance with conservative brexit ears
to try and for walk this planet well
we're not talking four we obviously have
nothing to do with Tory brexit is they
can decide whether they support the plan
or not but we've been very consistent
chioma at the very beginning of this
process set out is six red lines we've
talked about we we're the ones that
demanded a transitional arrangements
because we needed to give business
comfort that they could plan ahead
protective jobs in the country
particularly in the manufacturing sector
which is important in the Midlands and
the north of England and we've been
pretty consistent in that and we you
know we don't think that the pion are
set out by Teresa my so far we'll add
ear to those red lines thing is though
it feels a minute like we're standing on
the precipice here there's not much time
left there is a deal on the table it
might not be perfect you might not agree
with all of it but at the moment it
feels like it's the only plan the
government currently has what are the
alternatives
surely the responsible thing for the
opposition to do is to put party
politics
aside and say maybe this is the best
we're gonna get I believe me Sophie I do
understand what you're saying there and
I you know I worry about this all the
time when you represent a manufacturing
heartland like I do in West Brahmaji
East in the Midlands you know the you
can literally feel the pressure but we
have to get the right deal you know and
we've said to the government you know
come listen to me we might not get any
deal at all
well we you know right right I mean the
problem we have with parliamentary
arithmetic and the meltdown that's going
on in the government at the moment we're
sort of key brexit ears leaving the
cabinet is is sometimes very difficult
to see whether Teresa may could get a
majority within our own party for our
own plan actually could a few back to
they can't that's the point that's why
labor has got such a responsibility here
well we understand the responsibility
and we understand the pressure that that
brings as well but we're not negotiating
we're not the negotiating team and we've
been consistent for two years now we've
been saying look these are our concerns
these are our red lines please talk to
us about this we've got the interest of
the country at heart as well and we'll
work with you if you if you listen to
our arguments because there are some who
would look at the deals on the table
think there's not that much that
separates the checkers plan with what
Labor's saying neither if you want you
know a hard border in Northern Ireland
both of you say you know that you want
to follow a regulation to try and make
trade easier you know both of you say
you want to end free movement of people
but you want easy access to the jobs
market what I mean what are those red
lines a bit confuse had this 10,000
decisions but I mean for example for us
we've always said every interview I've
ever done when I think I've done it with
you I've done it well wherever we've
done it we said we want a jobs first
breaks it we want to protect the rights
of British work and then and but then
you look at the appointment of dominic
rap a man who has said that he thinks
our labor standards are too low and the
brics it gives us an opportunity to
reduce the security that already
insecure workers have got we can't sign
up to a plan that does that so you're
talking there about Dominic Rob's past
commutation so I'm talking about the
difference the actual difference between
the Chequers plan on the table and
labour supposition of Britain and I'm a
bit unclear what those massive
lines are that would risk a know do
brightly purse at a pointer to a brexit
into the brexit secretary Dominic Raab
has said he wants to undermine the
limited securities that British when did
he say that he said he said that since
he's been a net Member of Parliament we
have it since he's been breaks it
doesn't matter if I'm looking to but if
you're looking to build if you're
looking to build confidence in the
Opposition in your plan appointing
Dominic rap was a controversial act now
he might want to come to us and reassure
us that British workers will be secure
in their plan but right now we're very
we're very unconfident about his ability
to deliver this so what you're saying is
that you're prepared to risk and no
dough breaks that you're prepared to
look at your constituents in the face
because it's something that one member
of the cabinet has said since I know I'm
not saying that Sophie I'm saying that's
one example of why we have very little
confidence in Theresa Mays plan and her
ability to deliver it and frankly for
you to say it's down to us to deliver a
plan when she can't even deliver her own
cabinet is a little bit rich you know
what we want is a plan that puts jobs
and businesses first right we've said it
on the customs union we've outlined our
position on the single market we've
talked about how we want proper
environmental standards we want
guaranteed for human rights we want
guarantees for workers in the workplace
if the government can't even give us
that and please don't try and say he's
down to us to deliver a half-baked plan
that will leave millions of workers
worse off because we're not going to do
it now there it feels though that the
checkers plans on the table the prospect
of No Deal is something that's worrying
a lot of people there is potentially a
third way there wasn't there a people's
vote a second referendum is delayed by
taking that off the table or is it
something that you can count on in some
certain option in certain situations
it's not our policy to have a people's
vote
we've not called for it it wasn't in our
referee it wasn't in our manifesto but
actually as a result of last week it
seems to me that to take that off the
table completely when there might be a
set of circumstances where Parliament
cannot deliver a meaningful vote would
be a mistake but we don't want that we
don't think we've to think of people's
vote we don't actually want that what we
want is
what we've called for consistently for
the last two years which is a meaningful
vote in parliament mps to discuss the
plan and the ability to suggest changes
to that plan so that so that we can have
comfort that there is a majority in a
democratically elected House of Commons
would you prefer to see people's votes
over a node also yes yes we wouldn't
know well over a No Deal so I've thought
over well we need to see what they we
need to see the deal right and really
what we've said on this is how could you
possibly close down at your options when
you've not actually even seen the deal
completed in Europe I mean this is a
plan that so far has had what nine days
in existence David Davis is making a
speech in the House of Commons tomorrow
and told Boris Johnson is writing things
next week her own Teresa made his own
plan might not last the fortnight so I
think for us to sort of try and close
things down before we see how that plays
out would be a mistake some people could
see that as a betrayal people who voted
Brack said in the referendum they'll see
that this is politicians just trying to
stop it well thank you for giving me the
opportunity to reassure people that
that's not what you want we are leaving
the EU Labour MPs voted to trigger
article 50 this is all about the deal we
get when we leave the EU and that's
important because there are millions of
families out there who need us to get a
good deal they want you know we need to
give them comfort in the workplace the
idea that they could still have economic
prosperity and the generations to come
will be able to find good and fulfilling
work okay now let's move on to something
that we might get a bit more consensus
on and that is the World Cup and
everyone's been enjoying the football
recently of course it's been one of
those amazing kind of and summer
distractions from politics and right
there you want us to try and host the
World Cup in 2030 tell us about the plan
yeah well I've been driving my kids
crazy because I remember I'm old enough
to remember Italian nighti when we got
through to the semi-finals and the
country was alive then and actually
after a very difficult year see in the
country United this this last few weeks
it's been fantastic and it seems to me
you look at Premier League football
which is the best in the world you look
at a lower league football which is
really well run the Football Foundation
has made investments
grassroots football is the national game
it could bring the country together it
can give us hope we were disappointed in
2018 when we did the World Cup bid seems
to me that we should be bidding for the
World Cup 2030 and that's a few years
off and we don't know who's going to be
in government in a few years time if
we're in government I hope it's one of
the first things a Labour government
does which is work with our FA to try
and put a World Cup bid together if the
Conservatives are still in government
then we'd like to work with them to make
sure that a bid is successful and the
next country to host the World Cup is
Qatar do you think that's the right
place to be doing it well actually
there's obviously being very great
concerns about the way the construction
workers have been treated in Qatar and
the government of Qatar owes
acknowledged that they made some very
bad mistakes in the early days of that
thanks to our trade unions and actually
the British Health and Safety Executive
I think they've put in a sort of piece
of work that has actually helped deal
with that but in terms of the running of
the World Cup I think it looks like the
planning of it is very very good they're
obviously doing it in a winter near
close to the winter which will sort of
bring the temperatures down out in Qatar
will create havoc in all this sort of
national leagues which may cause some
tension in the UK but you know one would
hope that it would be a very very good
World Cup and that the squad we put out
in the last one will be a bit more
mature and battle-ready ready to go even
further than they did this time